the border between Chad and Sudan is
porous and Wild
lately you can see smoke rising in the
distance faint and far away but those
living here say that is al-janaina the
capital of West Darfur burning the most
active hot spot in Sudan's conflict
second only to hartum
unarmed villagers caught up in violence
a consequence of the fight for control
of a country refugees here say they
escaped in the night searching for days
to find a safe Crossing
they describe gangs of armed men in
vehicles harassing them raiding their
Villages holding them against their will
and killing people
not everybody came we left the old
people they're still there we can't go
back to get them we don't know what to
do we don't have anything to go and
fight these people maybe the government
of Chad can help us rescue the elderly
there is concern what is happening there
could happen here
driving up here we could see plumes of
smoke Rising all along the horizon in
different areas on the Sudanese side of
the Border if we were to start walking
we'd be on the other side of the Border
in Sudan in about 10 minutes when we got
here the people that had fled those
Villages told us that those were their
homes on fire and that they still have
people there
Chad's Army garrisoned additional troops
at Audrey when the violence broke out in
Sudan
one local leader said in Chad there is a
soldier under every tree a warning to
Armed groups on the other side of the
Border
humanitarian corridors remain open but
the military is on high alert
there is an African proverb that says if
your neighbor's Hut is on fire you must
prepare yourself so yours doesn't catch
fire too
[Music]
refugees should feel at home here he
says but cross-border attacks into Chad
have happened in the past
built up areas offer some protection
Villages would be as vulnerable as those
on the Sudanese side
's family lives in Chad but her Farm is
in Sudan she says it's been occupied by
Raiders her son and husband are stuck
there
we just need help bring us security we
need security to remain here with us
yesterday there was also smoking a lot
of gunfire we hear this all day we're
afraid all day because the smoke is so
close we can see it
hear the lives of Sudanese and chadians
straddle the imaginary lines that divide
their countries
they share the same space the same
vulnerabilities as the newly exiled who
can only look back at home where loved
ones are left behind
perhaps yet unaware of a sobering
statistic
most refugees who come here from Sudan
never go back
Zain basavi Al Jazeera wandalo Eastern
Chad